a couple minutes go downstairs I was
somebody said they were coming to the
lecture and they asked them what opening
do you want they're not even here but
they picked the Marshall attack or the
Marshall gambit ended up Rory Lopez so
we'll go over that just because I also
happen to know a game that I can show
you and it's a really good game some
people might know it it's the first time
the Marshall gambit or the Marshall
attack has ever been played in it occurs
in the Rue Lopez we're going to get
serious right away
so II 45:9 f3 knight c6 and Bishop b5
the reuleaux PES you know the oldest and
one of the most popular openings and at
all levels Club level it's very popular
Grandmaster level still very popular and
the most common move here is a six and
for those unfamiliar with this opening I
get asked this a lot people say well can
can I just take the knight and take the
pawn
well the exchange variation is not very
popular and one of the reasons is Black
has a decent move in this position that
helps them get his pawn back at least
does anyone know at the move is Aaron
qd4 exactly so you attack the knight you
attack the pond and this situation gives
me another chance to talk about a very
famous game that was played here at the
Chess Club I've talked about it on all
my other Roy Lopez videos but it's
always fun to talk about so this was the
game between a I think was 1500 and a
1300 here at the Knights tournament so
decent respectable players but what
moved in white play some of you guys in
the room I probably told the story too
already
well what was like the greatest move the
white could ever play here
Queeny to is the main move and right
king f1 is the only other legal move
right but if you're you're limiting
yourself to legal moves if you expand to
two more illegal moves
what would white play it's hard to guess
but here Aaron castles so the computer
won't let me do it but um that's a
missing okay that's a good oh really I
just disabled legal moves okay well here
it was white played castles so this was
a 1500 player and I was recording the
games because we send all the games for
the grandmasters and I saw I looked at
one score sheet and it's like castles
that's that's not right and the other
guy is you know 1300 it's castles but I
guess that was played and neither if I'm
caught it and then even after the game
I'm like did you guys really play this I
asked them both and they're both like oh
yeah I guess I played that and like I
guess that was illegal so it shows you
nice to run then white played rook e1
and white one really quickly um I assume
maybe I have to go away that was a rated
King what we do afterwards well no that
was played so I mean if you make an
illegal move and nobody catches it and
you just play that's that's the game you
don't go back in time and be like oh we
got to start over play again or you know
throw the game out or anything it's just
that's that was the game that's what was
played so we return again to the to move
a6 most commonly white keeps the bishop
on this diagonal and maybe in the future
we'll be able to actually threaten
taking and taking but with the the Queen
d4 move possible in certain lines right
now it's not actually a true threat okay
the most common move Knight f6 alright
you're attacking the pawn and here white
can castle there's there's other moves
but we're going to approach the main
line here and of course very popular at
the highest level is taking this and
playing the Berlin
game but the other main option is Bishop
e7 and okay if you're just going to play
the crew after rook e1 so the pawn is
protected so now we are indeed
threatening to take and take because now
our opponent is protected so we are
actually having that threat here black
expands on the Queen side with the move
b5 alright gains a turn on the bishop
and a very popular move here is just the
move d6 this will just enter the CRO
close drew Lopez very popular very good
respectable opening but a trickier move
is this move castles which keeps the
option of doing the Marshall attack
alive and okay White has done a lot of
things here just to avoid the Marshall
there's all sorts of anti Marshall moves
I mean like all these are moves there's
a whole bunch of moves that he can play
but in this opening I mean okay one of
the most natural moves you can play is
c3 I'm going to play d4 very typical Rui
Lopez and again we can play d6 closed
with Lopez very popular but tonight
we're going to focus on a very
aggressive gambit which is the move d5
so this is it's very powerful play it it
does lose upon white can take here and
then he can take twice on e5 and I want
to go over first a historical game so
the first time this game was ever played
and this was the game between kappa
blanka and frank marshall I believe it
was 1918 but Bensimon will put a bar
under here and we'll say some other date
and so this game was the first time it
was ever played and the the legend has
it Marshall who was playing with the
black pieces he prepared for 10 years
for this big game you know so he's going
to get kappa blanka you know he really
really wanted to beat him he's just
prepared you know so much and so he
plays kappa blanka and he loses so this
is a very difficult opening to refute in
Blanka did it for the first time over
the board so we'll have a look at at
that game there's a certain line the
Marshall played that's now just known
not to be very good but uh
alright let's accept all right and black
takes and we take they take
yeah we think so I mean what is this why
did we give up a pond here Black is
thinking about a very dangerous
initiative and in the game he went here
which is not the best move in modern
theory but what black is hoping to do is
in some way he's got to protect his
night so well if we have time we'll look
at a c6 game almost have to go find one
and here's how black gets a lot of
counter play for this pond his bishop
comes in the rook has to move away he's
got this Bishop the Queen he's got very
powerful attacking chances very often a
rook will come up and over very often
you know the hrf pawns will march down
the board and try to open up the white
king and you'll notice on the white side
the white king doesn't have a lot of
protectors around him and you'll also
notice these Queen side pieces are
really trapped in there and they're it's
not going to be so easy to get them out
but you are up upon so it is interesting
people you have different opinions some
people I guess I'm up upon some people
like the attacking possibilities and
there's a lot of top level players that
have played this way it's black so it's
it's not like anyone has just totally
refuted it just yet Aronian very
popularly he's known for for playing
this Carlsen's played it a couple times
and a lot of people have avoided it
players like Kasparov he never allowed
it in any of his games so alright not a
bad choice as far as gambits go it's
definitely not the most dubious so we'll
look at the move that Marshall played
and then hopefully we'll come back and
we'll look at the main line marshall
played this move Knight f6 which is not
supposed to be a very good move it's
just simply the knight is better here
and so in lines with c6 he needs to be
able to go to f4 for a part of blacks
attack but let's go over this game
because it's a very good game and I
happen to know it because I've taught it
to a couple students so hopefully I can
remember it
and so they achieved sort of the main
line with a kind of a funny
transposition here so nowadays everybody
here plays D for me there's other moves
those like d3 there's all sorts of moves
but the main line here is d4 now they
attack your rook
so you drop it back and black can
immediately start going in for an attack
so this is the main line normally why
detects the knife and you'll notice I
mean there's all sorts of possibilities
like blooming in the position all sorts
of sacrifices that white is going to
have to deal with and the main move here
is actually Queen h4 daring you to take
the knight but we'll see this in the
game so they got to that position a
rather funny way here and this is what
kappa blanka was good at this is a
tremendous game for demonstrating
defensive ability he every move it's you
really sees what marshal is going to do
even though this has never happened
before he sees Bishop d6 coming so he
just immediately goes back rook e1
alright Bishop d6 and h3 and perhaps he
was thinking all right I know what black
is gonna do he's gonna play Knight g4 h3
all right I stopped them and then
Marshall played this anyway
and why play d4 does anybody want to
take that night no nobody's interested
tonight
you know like Knights okay so if you
take this night you can get into a lot
of trouble starting with a move like
Queen to h4 anybody want to defend his
white
g3 okay I'm glad you said it
so this is kind of the move that you you
sort of want to play in this type of
position here but actually we have this
really powerful sacrifice vishal takes
g3 alright and if you take i take back
and when you move i'm just going to go
here i can take here this is this is not
good
i mean even if okay if you move your
queen or something there's there's all
sorts of bad stuff happening and
bringing my rooks in so there's all
sorts of bad stuff happening here so you
do have to be really really careful and
that's the problem
black does get these monster attacks
right away that can happen all the time
so okay i mean perhaps a better way is
Queen f3 though it's not that much
better I believe here black can just
play this move and then take here though
there was there's a funny line let me
see if I can remember the funny computer
line I think computer wants to go here
just I'll just test the audience here
because this is sort of a funny move so
alright it's starting to look good for
white you know maybe I've rappelled your
attack you certainly don't want to trade
queens if you're black I mean if you
look at the White King you're like
you're please please straight the
Queen's so I mean okay if you just take
the Queen and we trade that should be
pretty good for me and then I'd be
attacking both rooks so I'm going to
give you guys a chance to play with
black there's only one winning move here
and it's it's tough it's a double decks
clam
Bishop f4 excellent yeah okay you can
see this gets very very tactical very
quickly there's not a lot of good moves
I mean if you go here you get made it on
each one if you take here quite simply
you check and okay now you can you can
take this you can probably throw this
check in whatever you want to do however
you want to however you want to do this
which would be just obviously winning it
for black so you can tell it gets very
tactical very quickly and okay what a
what a nice resource official to f4 so
there's all sorts of tactics that can
happen so it's just it's well-known that
taking the night is just way too
dangerous
so very wisely he avoided that and you
just played the move d4 and now I went
to h4 or black with the h4 sorry
attacking f2
all right so white defended trying to
prevent sacrifices on f2
and again another shocker like just took
a lip - so why keeps making these moves
trying to stop black from doing things
but black just does them anyway and okay
I'll give you guys a chance to play like
kappa blanka it's a tall order but uh I
guess what would the audience play in in
this position what's the obvious move
recapture so this is actually a mistake
right yeah so I wonder what you would do
it is worth looking at this because I
mean I think that is the obvious move
does anybody know what black would play
here because this Bishop g3 is
unfortunate I take care
you take back your pins so that's
checkmate
so that actually is a very unfortunate
line which shows that you really do have
to be really careful here as white so
can anybody play a little bit better as
black here okay Bishop h2 I don't want
to just lose my queen so I'll go here
this is correct
and only now Bishop g3 the difference
being if you take now you get checked
and then black defense so it was very
important to misplace the white king to
get him to go to the F file to avoid
White's tactics that were also hiding in
the position okay so he took and all
right so he didn't just take although
it's probably still okay for him but I
think he noticed a rather funny aspect
in this position this Knight does it
really have anywhere to go
if you know he's where is he going
so nothing it's okay potentially there's
a sacrifice but he's trapped and at the
moment I mean black is thinking about
check and then taking your rook on a one
so kappa blanka just move this rook and
he's like alright what are you gonna do
and here there's all sorts of
possibilities for black in the game he
went here but it's also interesting to
know what I mean okay I think this also
sort of comes to mind there's all sorts
of these sacrifices we want to be
looking at the whole time but this just
like in the game is insufficient for
black because we take you take back
mg2 and even a line like this where you
check and we trade I can actually you
really don't have anything here as black
I can even just develop I move like 93
the point being I mean you can check me
once but you don't have any more checks
now after this you'll notice how my
queen really stops your queen for making
any checks or any threats against the
king
so here what would be fine obviously
there's still a lot of danger because
there's no phones in front of your king
but that should be fine
so perhaps you saw that and you decided
to play here which also is a very
aggressive move its man it's like what
do you do now well they took
all right Marshall in here
let's play our only legal move
you in here
still very complicated
he took
like when you
when there's one move it's easy to find
so right so it's still very complicated
position so white skiing is obviously
going to experience some slight
discomfort here but can he defend that's
always the battle in this opening and if
you just play a move like check or
whatever which seems kind of tempting
that's fine because my bishop that is
attacked you can just come and defend
for me so checking immediately doesn't
make as much sense
so he took here and again I would like
to challenge you guys this is another
great move by kappa blanka what would
you do here is white your kings you know
right there in the center wide open on
an open file your bishops attacked his
bishops attacked how are you guys going
to react to this also it's worth
mentioning the Black has this sort of a
threat in the position for example we'll
just make some bishop move here so black
is thinking about something like this
and even an aggressive move like c5 just
really trying to open it up I'm
threatening this I'm hoping you also
take here so I can use the open D file
there's there's lots of threats here so
we'll return to this position
oh yeah I mean this is great this is
what kappa blanka is is really known for
and okay this game is it's just a
defensive masterpiece really so what are
we going to do about this threat how are
we going to stop queenie one yeah
Bishop d2 exactly so that's what was
played
and okay the bishop is attacked so you
moved it
white one queen h3 attacking the queen
and the bishop obviously we don't want
to trade the Queens if we're black we
need the Queen to keep this this attack
going so he found a way to move his
queen out of the way with a with a check
and then move his Bishop out of the way
and say his bishop so the game went
check King d3 and you'll notice I'm
running to a very safe square c2 is sort
of the square for my king I need to be
safe surrounded by my pawns and now he
got his Queen now so we don't have to
trade Queens
this move is also check that's the white
king goes to see - now he's safe
but we do get a turn to move the bishop
and obviously it's not super easy to
play white and there's still a lot of
room to go wrong here you still have to
demonstrate how are you going to get
these guys into the game that at this
point is it's not obvious and white
decided okay up in your vision good luck
okay thank you wanna be pinned and now a
very good move and again oh how good
give you guys a chance to play like
kappa blanka but he is very good at
prophylactic thinking thinking about
what his opponent is going to do and
stopping them from doing it very famous
for that and if you guys I guess we're
black you know this is just a good
practice let's give them a move to your
opponent and if you were black and
you're trying to get some play here what
move would you want to play
yeah black for his part he wants to play
move like c5 open it up try to get some
access to your king I need to open up
some more files and I assume he took
this into account and he played a very
very good move here I assume there's
more than one good move you could play
but this is a very nice move Bishop d5
and we'll see why he did this okay
c5 are you really going to allow me to
take and open up the C file and you
can't really do that I'd like to Vic
and now we'll try to understand the
purpose of this move Bishop to d5
what did white have planned what could
this be
and the problem for white still is I
mean we have a little bit extra material
we have two pieces for the rook but how
you can activate your pieces you know if
you can just solve that problem
you'll be up material but how are you
going to do it so we'll start to see why
Bishop d5
in this position like beef or so this is
why he got the bishop out of the way so
he could play b4 and now after the
bishop moves how is he going to get
these pieces into the game
a4 exactly so he played a four I take
and now my rook is active so a very well
played game very well played maneuver
he's going to find a way to get all
these pieces into the game in so black
is you know probably fretting a little
bit you know white has played very well
and this is sort of his last chance to
really confuse the situation he needs to
try to do something to generate some
play here so a 5 so he's trying to open
things up to the maximum is you know if
I can just open a BC file if I can open
something up then maybe I'll get some
access to your king okay wait just took
and black took back and suddenly one
more piece is active for white here and
the rook went up right away
like tossed in this move which why you
should be fine with I just take back
with my night and now white is up
material and using all this pieces so
okay very very well played here and
what's what's the winning plan for white
and also it's quite remarkable just how
safe the white king is this Queens never
really going to be able to check me even
if your rip comes here I'm very well
shielded along the C file it's just
there's just no more counter play for
black but now how you going to make
progress you got this great position and
I having again I assume there's lots and
lots of right answers here but uh just
play b6
just push the button
black took
it takes back and I mean the white King
is just totally safe black maid lift
b7
black went to e3
and that was blacks last move now this
also is sort of important it gives me a
chance to talk about a theme I really
like to talk about so I'll challenge you
guys to find the best move here for
white which kappa blanka found Queen
takes pawn check I believe this is a
winning move by take and you can Queen
whoa check so this this does win indeed
something like this because I think
Harry you can actually take care because
your should be getting mated here soon
where's the meat I think I know
something like this I mean you're
getting mated and this does indeed win
for sure but this is also sort of an
important thing that I do like to talk
about so if you're playing with white
here you're just you're playing the guy
who's trained for this particular game
for ten years you know he spent all this
time and he had all these wild tactical
sacrificial ideas he was really trying
to blow you off the board this was
supposed to be Marshalls immortal game
you know he did all the prep that he
possibly had and kappa blanka had no way
of knowing that this was coming and to
find so many excellent defensive
resources along the way you really want
to finish this game off in style I mean
you you want to be a chess artist and
find the absolute best moves in every
single line and this is is going in the
textbooks I mean this guy really came
after you with a super aggressive
opening you know this is going to be
immortalized forever you got to find the
absolute best move here what's that
so this should also win like here I
guess
this probably wins I mean you can take
here and check me and I don't know this
probably wins did you want you can do it
you do it everyone but I shouldn't
taking my rope wins
I know you can even take care just claim
that I got more material maybe there's
better I don't know but I mean this this
should win so everything should win in
such a such a great position but it's
actually a meet in six and okay if you
find this the first move then you you've
done it right but uh Bishop takes pawn
check yes this is absolutely the crusher
fantastic and what a way to finish him
off I mean you really really showed him
by finding the absolute best move there
yeah I mean captain long it just saw
everything he defended perfectly and he
reviewed it a very difficult opening so
with when black played earlier the the
knight f6 line he just really found the
way that's I mean it's just incredible
so let's look at the point first of all
if you take here which I guess is the
main defense we can make it Queen and
okay if you go here what's the move
the ever takes pawn and you're going to
get this checkmate there's nothing else
that's good for black well it's going
even suggest okay if you go here it's
simple there's a pan so checkmate going
here immediately it's also relatively
simple I think okay you go here this
gets you may did and this gets you mated
so an incredible finish so real
masterpiece here but for white so the
guy that that had all the prep it just
didn't really matter but I don't want to
leave you guys I'm under the impression
that it's you know just a great great
for white here so let's let's actually
go back we'll relive the the opening and
we'll both try to find a game where
we're black one so let's flip it around
let's have a look at the the main line
now okay so we get the Roy Lopez a six
all right Knight f6 castles not taking
on e4 but playing Bishop e7 he protects
the pawn now he is threatening to take
on c6 okay we push him away and we
castle
and if you place c3 we really go for it
here with d5 sacrificing a little okay I
mean there's there's no reason not to
accept it and um alright let's see if we
can't find a game with the main move in
this position which is c6 so so this is
the the top-rated game that black one
here and it's Levon Aronian so he's one
of the main proponents of this as black
and there's all sorts of lines in this
that at the top level they've been
playing and even when the attack doesn't
work usually get a position where black
is down upon but there's always a way to
draw because it usually ends up some
broken pond ending down upon and 2728
hundreds are pretty good at drawing
those it's probably not what you want a
club level you don't want to be down
upon and suffering for a while but you
also can get really big attack here with
black in most games so I'll put this on
training well I guess how long is this
game okay 29 moves so it's a rather
short game which is good okay so we'll
see what happened here so c6 was the
last move and the night stays in a
location where you might jump in and the
other plans will be just about the same
the bishop comes here the Queen comes in
but we really want the knife to go to f4
it's a much more aggressive post than a
g4 as we saw in the last game and why
played d4
very sensible I assume Bishop d6 and so
the Rope has to retreat and I assume
Queen h4 and so this so far is the
mainline g3 is anybody attempted to play
h3 is that what you're going to say
you know hmm
yeah okay I'll take it
he takes fun ah so it's kind of annoying
um yeah I guess I have to play move like
this yeah
take take my room you probably should
take the work now what is going on here
so something like this with the plan of
this is very strong this is it's quite
dangerous for white to face you know so
if you can go here I mean I guess I'll
so I can just take the pawn if I want
and threaten this sort of a thing even
if you go here I go here or I can go
here in here yeah this looks very very
dangerous for white which is why h3 is
definitely not the move so in the game
g3 and okay
the most common there's a typical idea
that happens here for black once you
force them to play g3 you put the Queen
on h3 and then because you want to stay
somewhere where your queen is in contact
with the g4 square because that's the
good square for your Bishop and then a
really funny thing that often happens is
once you get your Bishop to g4 you
actually bring your queen back because
the bishop wants to go to h3 so that is
that's very typical so we'll see if that
happens in our game here Queen h3 the
next move is Bishop g4 and so okay how
is white going to defend I think the
most common way is Bishop e3 and then 92
also the Queen can go to one of these
two squares and then try to go to f1 to
evict the black Queen that's also
another idea
in the game Bishop e3 alright so he's
just isn't going to develop all of his
pieces he's up upon and black better get
some sort of attack going and you'll
you'll notice this the potential for
stuff on the light squares over here is
really nice for black because the other
fish
is all the way on the other side of the
board Bishop g4 and we move this Queen
okay and so again I mean this is a
possible move coming up in the future
also the night might go to d2 so I
assume there's a lot of things what I
could do we can centralize the stroke so
you could play queen h5 immediately okay
you brought a rook in
ninety-two
so how is black going to get an attack
here that's that's what we're waiting to
find out like me to try you can play
rookie six teenage five
a four so kind of like how kappa blanka
did when this rook went away a four
followed by taking on b5 opens the a
file for the white rook okay very
interesting all right
rookie six here it comes
very interesting so what's that going to
do let's see okay takes takes back okay
good deal for white
nine f1
so he's sort of defending
okay Bishop f5 and how is black going to
get in an attack here so maybe he's
thinking he's going to attack the Queen
and then when if she moves somewhere
eventually we can go here and in general
another way to get more attackers in
here for black is ideas with like H 5 H
4 or F 5 F 4 so how is he going to range
such a thing okay
we just went back to D to mr. Bates
three okay fantastic all right it's act
McLean
wasn't cleaning this might actually be
good for black is now I I mean I have
these ponds I can start throwing a match
yeah gotta open up some more stuff here
okay it's a white has found a way to
transfer the bishop so maybe go go back
and trade maybe he'll just call it
dekhta h1 if it gets attacked and
alright so it's doing a pretty good job
defending and this game is going to end
in six moves Wow all right
when the five
mr. went all the way back
look goes the e 8mm up this games about
to end
yeah it's just a couple moves it was 29
moves if I remember right so we got 5
more moves so how something's gonna
happen
rookie - all right in some lines - you
know if I ever get to do this in this ok
the rook defends maybe also he's
thinking about Queen here I don't think
he's thinking about doubling because
this rook is already so good on the a
file some as soon maybe the reason is he
wants to go here
h5 ok now black is getting serious h 5 h
4 and then all sorts of sacrifices on g3
this is looking quite deadly
okay does black want to trade Queens no
of course not we're on the attack here
we got to keep the Queens on the board
let's see if LaVon agrees with that
alright Queen to g4 alright my next move
is h4 and then I start taking on g3
rook 1 back perhaps now why it's going
to challenge the Queen again I don't
really see what White's doing in this
game
he's just been sort of moving around
game is about to end
how's this game gonna end h4 and yes
stuffs about to happen I'm about to take
on g3 maybe I'll take on f1 first really
knows Queen d1 do you think black will
trade this this is going to be the last
move of the game what's white gonna play
here this is the last mode of clean of
three
I mean we don't want to trade queens and
stem it was at the last move all right
so that was the last move of the game
and presumably white resigned there's a
Grand Slam final game so I don't think
it was a blitz game or like they lost on
time or something but perhaps black is
is actually winning here maybe I'm
threatening to just wrap this Queen okay
even if you go back I have h3 so
presumably the the threat is to trap
your queen and so we got to do something
about that I'm thinking Queen d1 but if
anybody else has any ideas
I assume Queen d1 and then there's all
sorts of taking on g3 maybe I take this
knife first no take the knight and I
don't know perhaps you should be careful
because I'm taking here a bunch and I'm
like taking here a bunch all sorts of
ways so it might be sensible to take
this tonight and I can take back I might
even be able to take on g3
well let's do this it seems more fun
and I assume you take back
nice to make they take this at some
point and then there's gonna be all
sorts of stuff going on here so
something like this is just crushing for
black so if you take I can take on e3
that looks very good for me
that's why it must have seen something
like this and Queen f3 Queen f3 I ever 6
so somehow this this looks very strong
for black look go back just for a second
here does anybody okay so so black just
played Queen g6 does anybody want to
defend this as white any better
it's very difficult so that was sort of
a very surprising twist all of a sudden
the game just ended but uh okay in that
was I guess a good demonstration for how
to play this as black the sort of attack
that you can get out of nowhere and what
did sort of seem to play lazily I
suppose is a good word he just kept
attacking the Queen but black just never
traded and and white just ultimately
blundered we can show you here it says
Queen d1 and it just takes right away it
alright if you take back so we get this
same sort of line so in some way there's
these sacrifices which okay so this is
the computer line and okay this is this
is crushing the movies g4 which is kind
of funny so a very very powerful display
by black I mean like just blundered
there at the end but hopefully that
gives you guys a little bit of insight
into the commercial attack